- I think your audience
needs to know something.
Cause I don't talk
about it a lot.
Every single second,
every word I say,
and every conservative
is saying on airways,
but it seems like Fox, talk
radio, podcasts like yours.
Trust me, you are going to
experience a lot of this
as your popularity has
grown by leaps and bounds.
You've already got--
- I get my share.
- You get your share,
and I've seen it.
And what people don't
know is literally millions
and millions of
dollars are being spent
to record every
single word we say.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin report.
A quick reminder
everyone to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and click
that pesky notification bell
so that you see our videos
and joining me today is the
host of Hannity on Fox News,
as well as the host of the
Sean Hannity radio show
and author of the new book
"Live Free or Die America"
and "The World on the
Brink," Sean Hannity,
finally welcome to
"The Rubin Report."
- Well thank you for having me.
Thank you also, because you
have been an incredible addition
to the TV show.
We've got to get
you on radio more.
We have a regular ensemble
cast, you're now a part of that.
Our audience loves you,
the feedback's phenomenal.
I know how popular
this podcast is.
You are outspoken,
iconoclastic, a free thinker,
independent, believe in freedom
and liberty and free speech
and you're not part of the
cancel culture and boycott
and shut everybody down
that you disagree with.
And frankly, isn't it
crazy that we conservatives
are those guys that
we're the ones,
no, I don't want
to cancel anybody,
boycott anybody or
get anyone fired.
Let people decide, let people
have freedom of choice.
- Yeah, well, I suppose
I could just let you go
and say nice things
about me, but I'll start
because I actually got
the book yesterday.
I read about half of it so far,
but I want to start with exactly
what you just said there,
because you said it to me
on air a couple of weeks ago
and I thought it made
a really good point
that you get boycotted
all the time.
You know, media matters
and the rest of these guys,
they're constantly coming after
you trying to take you out,
take out your sponsors,
et cetera, et cetera.
But you personally never
called for a boycott
for any of the guys that
are doing far worse stuff
in my opinion then you're doing.
Could you just talk a little
bit about what it's like
to just be in that
machine all the time,
just be in that
atmosphere of boycotts
and the rest of it
all of the time.
- I think your audience
needs to know something.
Cause I don't talk
about it a lot.
Every single second,
every word I say,
and every conservative
is saying on airways,
but it seems like Fox, talk
radio, podcasts like yours.
Trust me, you are going to
experience a lot of this
as your popularity has
grown by leaps and bounds.
You've already got--
- I get my share.
- You get your share
and I've seen it.
And what people don't
know is literally millions
and millions of
dollars are being spent
to record every
single word we say
in the hopes that we say one
word, one phrase, one sentence,
there's one paragraph that
either they don't like,
or they'll take out of
context or they'll clip
so that they could
either boycott us
to make us financially not
viable, which you know,
there is a business aspect
of being on the air.
It's not cheap to be on the air,
whether it's a podcast
or radio show or TV show,
because they want
to silence you.
I can give you my track record.
Going back to the
time that Bill Maher.
I'll be very Frank,
I hate Bill Maher.
I don't like his show, I
think it's gotten worse.
I think he's radical, extreme.
I disagree with
pretty much everything
that's come out of his mouth.
I've had him on as a
guest a number of times,
but I do respect his
iconoclastic style.
I do respect that
he'll say things
that he knows will upset people,
but it was people
like myself when ABC
was canceling
"Politically Incorrect"
that said, no,
don't cancel this.
Literally standing up for him.
Now we'll never get
credit for that.
I've never had or witnessed
liberals or liberal groups.
Now they say they're
for free speech.
They're pro choice,
but they're not.
Because every time there
is any effort to boycott
any conservative voice,
libertarian voice
or any voice they just don't
like, it's always okay,
we got to get them fired, get
them canceled, boycott them
so they're financially,
they're not viable anymore.
And then ultimately
what the goal is
is to get their
voice off the air.
Every single prominent
conservative,
this is not a small effort.
We are talking about 10s and
10s of millions of dollars
to do this, and it's done,
it's an intimidation tactic.
And it's funny because
I could tell you,
I can give you a long list
of people that, for example,
I had a huge Twitter
feud with Jimmy Kimmel.
It went on for a while
and, and I won Adam Hart.
And I reminded him of all those
stupid things that he said.
It all started cause
he was making fun
of Melania Trump's accent
when she was reading
books to children.
I'm like, are we really
going to pick on women?
And then I brought up all the
old videos of him, you know,
as Karl Malone, right?
Putting like cucumbers in his
pants and approaching women
from old shows he did.
And then I would
always hashtag Disney
cause I always knew
Disney had no appetite
for a controversy.
Not to get him fired,
but to send a message,
if you're going to be a jackass,
I can be a jackass back.
Now when he really came
under fire recently
and apologized for
that older skit
as it relates to Karl Malone,
like Jimmy Fallon did
only a year earlier,
not once that I even comment
on it, I stayed out of it.
I had had my fight with him.
I'm not a boycotter,
I'm not a canceler.
I actually believe that people
should have the
freedom of choice.
People have to choose to
listen to my radio show,
watch my TV show and
sign up for your podcast,
which is enormously popular.
It's one of the most popular
podcasts out there now
and all credit to you,
but you're a target too.
Why is it the left doesn't
stand up for freedom
and liberty and free
thought and expression
and the free open
exchange of ideas?
You know, I'll say this too.
They act like
they're so outraged.
Donald Trump outrageous
and they wake up,
Donald Trump says this or
that, they're outraged.
It is selective, feigned, moral,
outrageous, it is not real.
It is phony, it is selective
because they want
to act all outraged.
They're not that outraged,
if you're that offended by what
you're hearing on the radio
or watching on TV or choosing
to watch on a podcast,
if you don't like
it, turn the dial.
I don't want people
turning the dial.
I actually, I want
to build my audience,
but I'm not going to
compromise who I am,
what I want to say or
the values I stand for
because they're going
to try to intimidate me
and silence my voice.
I'm not going to allow it.
I am going to fight
until my dying breath,
but I'll also fight for
their right to do and say
what they want to say.
They've lied, you know,
the media in general,
they've 99% of them have been
lying to the American people
from the day that Donald
Trump and Melania Trump
came down that escalator
at Trump tower, you know,
it has been lies and smears
and slander and besmirchment
and libel and character
assassination.
It has been conspiracy theories,
one false conspiracy
theory after another,
one hoax after another, you
want to talk about hypocrisy?
I'll give you
breathtaking hypocrisy
if you want me to keep
going here because--
- All right, well,
even though I know
you don't talk about
this that often,
as long as we've sort of
done the boycott thing,
can you just talk about
the personal side of it?
Because one of the
things that now
that I've done more of
the cable news shows,
and I've gotten to know
some of you guys, you know,
I think the average person
doesn't really think
you guys are human.
Like there's sort of this
feeling like you guys
just live in that box,
you live in that box
and they only know you
as that personality, right?
They know you, Sean Hannity
on the Hannity program.
He talks, he goes,
he interviews.
But can you talk a little
bit about the personal cost
of just dealing with that
nonsense all the time?
- You know, for me personally,
whatever switch maybe
you're supposed to have,
that you care about what
you read about yourself,
I tell, it's interesting.
I'll back up and tell
you a backdoor story
to get to your answer,
is that there will
always be new people.
I'm like the old guard at Fox.
I've been there since October
96 when we went on the air.
I'm sort of like the
veteran on the team, right?
But there will always be
new people that come in
and work at Fox and I always
try to be nice and helpful,
whatever I can do
to help people.
I'm a believer that it's
not a zero sum game,
a rising tide lifts all boats.
My success is not predicated
on other people's failure.
I've never believed that at all.
I champion and cheer
people's success,
but inevitably they
get to that moment
where they're on the air
and then they get the
first negative article
or they get the first attack
and they are broken up
and they're in pieces.
And I'm like,
okay, first of all,
welcome to the big leagues.
Congratulations, wear it
is a badge of honor, right?
You're making a difference,
you're being noticed.
Secondly, I say, if you want
to feel better about yourself,
go Google my name
because when you do,
SeanHannityisamoron.com,
SeanHannityissatan.com,
SeanHannityisLuciferonsteroids.,
whatever it happens to be.
So whatever switch
I'm supposed to have
that gives a flying rip.
I would say otherwise, you know,
I'll be on my R
rated side today.
- Hey, this is podcast land.
You can say whatever you
want, man, we don't even--
- I don't give a shit.
There's your answer,
I don't care.
The switch doesn't exist.
Now, on the other hand, I
have an 18 year old daughter
and a 21 year old son.
Now, my only concern
honestly is for them.
I don't even care about
like my extended family
or my sisters, they know
who I am, they know me.
And when people make false
allegations or attack you,
you know, my kids are so
used to it that honestly,
at this point I don't
even go to them with it
because they usually
don't hear about it.
My son will hear about it
only if it's on Barstools.
"Dad, you're on
Barstools today."
I'm like, okay, that means,
I guess I've made it, right?
- A sign of the times man.
- Thankfully, they don't care.
Sometimes I have to explain
to them and I remind them too
that there might
be people that know
that they're related to
me, that they're my kids,
that may not like me
and I always warn them
the upside and downside.
There's a lot of upside
for them, but that for me,
I didn't grow up
with famous parents.
I grew up with my mom,
a prison guard, my dad,
a family court probation guy
and a waiter on the weekends.
So it's very different, but
it's all they've known also.
They've been at events with
20 plus thousand people
at arenas that
I've been hosting.
So they've seen the people
that are also invested as I am
in what I love the most,
which is this country
and the things that I
believe in and the passion
and the freedom and
the liberty of America
and the dream that is America,
because I am that dream.
And you know, I could
talk more about that later
if you want but, so I don't
have the switch, I don't care.
I care about my kids when
they're impacted by it.
Everyone else, I don't care.
- So you mentioned a little
bit about your upbringing--
- By the way, one sec,
don't ever hit Google alert
that says Dave Rubin, don't
put that on your phone.
Don't read Twitter.
I can't even, I have no access
to my social media accounts.
I have to go through
an army of people
before I can send out my own
tweet, I have no passwords.
- Now I see how you
have that great hairline
because you're not on Twitter.
That's clearly the answer,
that's clearly the answer.
So a couple of weeks
ago I was on the show
with you with Dan
Bongino and I mentioned,
I was Googling something
right beforehand
and I saw that you were
born in New York city.
It turned out that
Dan was born in Queens
and I was born in Brooklyn
and I mentioned it on air.
And I thought, you know,
maybe there really is
something there that
people born in New York
for as out of whack,
especially as New York
city under DeBlasio is,
and Cuomo is governor,
for as out of whack
as New York is,
maybe there really is something
special about New York.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
Because you're a
true New York guy.
You still live in New York.
- You can add to that
like Bill O'Reilly, right.
You can add to that
a guy Tom Leykis.
Tom Leykis was a highly
successful host nationally
and started and spent a lot
of his career in Los Angeles.
It probably has to do
with being very outspoken.
Now I left New York and
pursued a whole other life.
I was out of New York 16
years and I started radio.
You probably weren't
born yet Dave.
1987 was the first time I
got behind a radio microphone
Close?
- I was 11 Hannity, come on.
- You what?
- 11.
- Oh you were 11, okay you
look great, you know why?
Cause you have a lot
slicker hair than I do
and you've gotta be
using Just for Men
and I've never used Just
for Men, so I'm teasing.
- No nothing, this
is all natural.
- All natural, you
got it right here.
And some people used to
write me "Is your hair real?"
and I'd be pulling it
on air, yeah, it's real.
But you know, I like
outspoken people.
I like people that are not
afraid to express their views.
And honestly, if you
go through your life
and you care about what
people think about you
and it stifles you
and it silences you
and it boxes you in, either--
I always say on radio and TV,
I'm on the air four hours a day.
This is all extemporaneous our
discussion here today, right?
And you can't fake it
for four hours a day.
People see through
BS, they see it.
And what you hear and what
you see is what you get.
Radio is more of a
warmth heart medium.
I have three hours,
TV I have an hour.
It's fast paced,
it's a lot of news.
We're getting a ton
of information in it
and I feel like we're doing work
that nobody else in
the media is doing.
People like yourself and
you mentioned Dan Bongino
help out a lot.
You know, you've been a
phenomenal addition to the show.
So, but I don't want
to live my life,
giving a flying rip what
some idiot keyboard warrior
in their underwear in
their parents' basement
at 60 years old cares
about me or says about me
anonymously on some
social media site.
That's why I have no
access to any of it.
I don't ever read it.
- You just handed us the
clip, that's the promo clip.
I mean, that was a tailor
made promo clip right there.
The guy in his underwear.
- Not me, the keyboard
warriors that are psycho.
- Oh not you you.
- No not Hannity, Hannity
is not in his basement
in his underwear anonymously
typing out I hate Hannity.
That's not me.
- Oh, alright, well they'll
still come after you for it.
- Probably.
- Does the grind of it,
the fact that you're doing
all those hours on the radio,
then you're doing
your hour at night
and that you always have
to have something to say,
and I know with you
that it is authentic,
but that the, you know,
we went from, you know,
network news to
ultimately cable news.
Then it was 24 hours
and now in effect
it's every time
Trump tweets, I mean,
we're in a five
second news cycle now.
Do you think any of that
is actually part of
the problem right now?
Sort of why we're all kind
of crazed about politics?
- I'm for more information,
not less information.
I could tell you when I
first started in radio,
I mentioned the light
went on first time.
I believe it was 87,
no later than 88,
which makes me 32 plus years
in radio, that's a long time.
And I remember my first
professional radio gig
where I actually got some money
was in Huntsville, Alabama.
I started in California.
And by the way, with
anyone starts on radio,
you're terrible.
And I was trying to, you know,
I guess I wasn't as authentic.
There's a great scene in
Howard Stern's "Private Parts."
That's my life, I lived
the same life he did.
- I've seen it a billion times.
- Except I do a different
form of radio, right?
It's very different, but
I know what it's like
when you start out on radio.
"All right, here's the
weather, hazy, hot, humid,
a chance of late
afternoon thunderstorms.
Right now it's 78 degrees,
sunny, a chance of storms
and more of the hits
of the 70s, 80s and 90s
coming up right here on
WWWW," or whatever, right.
You just want--
- Remember, it was WNBC.
- It would be in his case, yeah.
But he shows that and I did
that I mean, when I started.
You're terrible when you start.
It was interesting because
you're starting in this whole,
there's a whole other path
that wasn't open to somebody
like myself, but there
were more opportunities.
There actually were
talk radio stations
that hired young guys,
sort of like the farm
league that maybe one day
some of them might be able
to get to a bigger market.
And you know, I started
to get thrown out of town
in California, I deserved it.
Totally, you know, awful.
I go to Huntsville, Alabama,
I arrived there in 1990.
And then I worked there two
years and I went to audition
in Atlanta for two
nights, I got hired.
I spent four wonderful years
in the city of Atlanta.
I'd love to talk about that.
I got to know these
civil rights leaders.
You know, we recently
lost John Lewis.
I have nothing politically
that I agree with John Lewis,
except that in the
first day in Atlanta,
I got a call to my radio show
from then mayor Maynard Jackson.
But I got to know
Joseph Lowery, the SCLC.
They all come on my program.
The mayor would
come on my program.
Hosea Williams was my
favorite guest ever,
a really close friend of
Martin Luther King Jr.
John Lewis, Andy Young,
and I don't think
Andy liked me much,
but with all these guys,
I knew when I got to know
their story and it was one of
great courage and conviction.
And if you look at
Selma to Montgomery,
if you look at fire
hoses and dogs,
and I learned this lesson,
you see the peaceful
protest of that time.
They helped make this
a more perfect union.
They put it all on the line.
Here's an interesting side
note to this, you know,
because we watched
the eulogy with Obama.
The eulogy Obama gave it at
the John Lewis remembrance
and all the politics
that he brought up,
which I found outrageous.
- It was a political speech.
- It was, it was awful.
But he talked about the
John Lewis extension
of the Voting Rights Act.
And I'm thinking,
well, hang on a second,
because the guy that's leading
your ticket, Joe Biden,
the ever corrupt,
ever forgetful, ever
out of it Joe Biden.
Well, Joe Biden says his
mentor and his dear friend
was Robert Bird,
the former Klansman.
By the way, Hillary
said it, Bill said it,
Schumer said it, Pelosi said it.
So former president
Obama was talking about
these historic bills that
John Lewis absolutely
along with so many
others bravely fought for
and made us a more
perfect union.
Not perfect, we still
have a long way to go.
And yet they're
talking about the act,
but the guy that's running
actually supported the guy
that filibustered that
historic legislation.
People don't know and
this drives me nuts.
Every two years,
every four years,
what do they say
about Republicans?
It's every election cycle,
Republicans are racist,
sexist, misogynist, homophobic,
xenophobic, Islamophobic.
They want dirty air and
water, a Paul Ryan lookalike.
There'll probably be a Donald
Trump look alike this year,
is going to take
granny in a wheelchair
after she's only eating
dog or cat food for a year
and throw her over the
cliff in the wheelchair.
That's every two and four
years, it is atrocious.
I went through on
Hannity this week
a history of how this happens
every two and four years.
Well, the Civil Rights
Act, Lyndon Johnson needed
in the Voting Rights
Act, 80% Republicans,
80% Republican in
the house and Senate.
And then you have the mentor
of their democratic presidential
candidate praising the guy
that filibustered that bill.
I mean, that's madness to me.
That's the guy that when
integration was coming up,
talked about kids and
integration of school
as a racial jungle that
he was worried about.
Well, Donald Trump said this--
- This is an actual quote,
this is an actual quote.
So I think a lot of people
are waking up to this
and I think that's partly
because suddenly, well,
suddenly people can
see the clips online
where in the old days
you couldn't really
see the clips, right?
What do you think happened
to the Republicans
or to the GOP or
to conservatives
that let this thing
get so confused?
That the reality of
the history compared
to the way it's portrayed,
is that purely just
a media concoction
or do the Republicans have
some blame there themselves?
- No republicans, generally
Republicans have gotten weak.
I'll give you an example.
I said they're weak, they're
timid, they're spineless,
they're visionless, I
said that for a long time.
When Republicans
finally elected, well,
we finally got a Republican
president that would repeal
and replace Obamacare.
Where were the Republicans
that voted 60 some odd times
to repeal and replace?
They disappeared
and they never even
had an alternative in place.
I had an alternative, you know,
either patient power or
a Cato Institute book
by Musgrave and Goodman
that I read years ago
or a doctor that I
often put on my show,
Dr. Josh Umbehr, who
created in Wichita, Kansas,
a healthcare cooperative.
It's only 50 bucks a
month, 24/7 concierge care.
He negotiates directly with
pharmaceutical companies.
Guess what, 50 bucks
a month for an adult,
10 bucks a month for a child,
a doctor available 24/7.
You walk out with the medicines
at a 90, 95% reduced rate.
You add that with a
catastrophic plan.
If God forbid you
have a heart attack,
cancer or a bad accident,
they weren't ready.
And then the senators actually
voted, Republican senators,
seven of them voted
for the exact same bill
that they voted on
two years prior,
just a straight repeal bill.
That would've meant something,
it didn't mean anything.
So I'm angry at them for that.
Now, in terms of
Republicans allowing
this false narrative
to go forward,
I do it every
election year, Dave.
I show the same clips, there's
a 1998 Missouri radio ad.
I went through this this week.
If you elect Republicans, you
know, a cross is going to burn
or the James Byrd ad in 2000,
that says it's like my father
was killed all over again
because George Bush didn't
support hate crime legislation
with this horrific
dragging death
of this innocent
man, James Byrd.
But George Bush did
support the death penalty.
So he wanted the guy dead,
you know, for that crime,
for that inhumanity, for
that evil and you know,
or Al Gore goes before a
predominantly African American
audience and he changes his
tone, his pitch, his cadence.
To me, it's like really?
He tries to sound
like he's a preacher
in a predominantly
African American church.
Republicans have the wrong
agenda for African Americans.
They don't even want to
count you in the census
or Hillary Clinton, same thing,
predominantly African
American audience.
I don't feel no ways tired.
I mean, what is this?
- She's got hot sauce, Sean.
She's got hot sauce in her
bag, don't forget that.
- Oh, I do remember
that, yes, indeed.
Or they're going to put
you all back in chains.
So this is the playbook.
I told everybody as
I started the year
and before I went on vacation
at the end of the last year,
it's coming, they will do it.
It's the playbook,
dirty air, dirty water,
racist, sexist, misogynist,
straight on through.
It's what frustrates
me about Mitt Romney.
Mitt Romney, the very same
people he's now embracing
are the very same people
that said he was a racist
and a sexist and a misogynist,
so that's frustrating.
- The same people,
he was running,
he had binders full of women.
They said he's a misogynist.
Now he's the hero.
- Binders by the way
with women's resumes
so he could hire them.
Okay, jeez, sorry,
I have a resume.
- That doesn't make it
into the tweets though.
You know, Twitter it's short.
So, you know, you
gotta pick it up.
- I'm in Twitter
hell, Twitter prison.
- You're smart, man, listen,
but is that what you just
described right there?
The repetitious nature of
the way this goes cyclically
every couple of years
and the rest of it,
is that why you have
became such a Trump guy
more than anything else?
Because he just was
like, he clearly saw it.
It's very obvious to me as a
guy that did not support Trump
last time that it's very--
So look, I'm here in
California where my vote
is sort of useless
in a certain regard.
So I voted for Gary
Johnson who was, you know,
he's a nice guy, but he
was a terrible candidate.
But, but that, but here we are.
That being said,
is that it for you?
Was that the thing that lit
in your brain with Trump,
that it was like,
he will fight that
and that is the most evil thing.
- You're asking great questions.
So there are certain
points of my career,
crossroads points if you will,
that I think define
moments that I think maybe,
in terms of the work
that I have done,
if it's any good or not, I'll
let other people judge it.
But when nobody else would
vet Barack Obama in 2007
and eight, and look
into his background
of Frank Marshall Davis, and
what is a community organizer?
What is Alinsky, who's Alinsky?
What are Alinsky
tactics, what's acorn,
what is black
liberation theology
that he wrote about in his
book that so inspired him,
"The Audacity of Hope."
Who was this preacher
he sat in the pews of
but 20 plus years, who is
Bill Ayers and Bernadine Dohrn
of the weather underground,
a domestic terrorist
organization
involved in numerous
bombing that he started
his political career
in their home.
Imagine if any Republican
that ever had the history
of any of this,
what would happen?
So as it relates to the
president, what I saw,
and I think what others saw,
I'm not a registered Republican,
I'm a registered
conservative, like you.
We're both very stupid
because you need
to get the hell
out of California
with the regulation
and taxation.
And I'm so stupid I'm in
the schiff hole of New York
and with high taxes
and burdens and regul--
I need to get out of here?
Every year my
accountant always says--
- But don't you like fighting
from the belly of the beast?
Cause I'm kind of--
- I don't like getting robbed.
They're robbing me blind.
I mean, and stupidly
and I'm working on it.
I'm going to get out of here,
but you know what
they take in taxes
and how difficult they make it.
If I told you what I
paid in property taxes,
your head would spin
around in circles
and you would projectile vomit,
you know, green pea soup,
like the Exorcist, it's insane.
I knew Donald
Trump for 25 years,
he would come on my local
radio show in New York city.
When I was on at night,
he would come on when I
was on an afternoon drive
before I was syndicated
when I just started at Fox
and I got to know
the person, the man.
Now, he was a little
more left when I met him,
but he was becoming
more and more right.
And I'll tell you where we
really, really connected.
It was over a disagreement.
No one has gotten this out
of me before, so this is new.
And the disagreement
was my support,
which I don't regret, of
after 9/11, the war on terror.
And, but I can
see in retrospect,
in many ways he was right.
We didn't have the sophisticated
ability of drone strikes
as we do today.
When I went to Baghdad, I
saw them, my first drone.
It was not at that point
being used like it is today.
Future wars are
going to be fought,
it's going to be
like Call of Duty.
And you're just going to be,
you're gonna have the command
center in Tampa, Florida,
and people they'll
press buttons.
They're looking at
a satellite shot
or like a Jason
Bourne movie, boom,
they're going to hit it
and you'll hit your target,
end of the war.
So it got complicated
as it went on longer,
once you're involved and you
know, it's hard to get out.
I supported the (talks quickly),
I liked George W. Bush.
I know he did the best he could.
He was a wartime president,
worst terrorist attack
in American history.
Trump's point was that okay,
if we're gonna fight the war,
let's take the oil and
make them pay for it.
That's not a dumb idea.
And he was like,
these longterm protracted
conflicts can't happen.
Now I would argue,
in retrospect,
military technology has
made that style of warfare,
it's completely outdated.
We better keep
modernizing our military,
which Donald Trump is doing.
And if we're going to fight
wars, we better win them.
I don't want to see
kids going door to door
in Baghdad again and
having their legs
and their arms blown
off and leaving
with these horrific
injuries that they have.
And I do believe
these other countries,
if we help them pay us,
we're gonna save you, pay us.
I do believe that the
president's right about that,
or Obama put in place and Biden
did the rules of engagement.
They put handcuffs
on our military.
If we're going to go to war,
go to war, win the war
and get the hell out.
And that means there's going
to be collateral damage.
If it's that bad that
our national security
and national interest are
at stake and it's that high,
then go fight it, win it
with overwhelming force.
The reason the president beat
back the caliphate in Syria
is because he took
off the handcuffs
that had been put on
by Biden and Obama
and he drove out the caliphate
completely from Syria.
He used modern technology.
We knocked out
Soleimani on a tarmac.
You know, he was on
a commercial flight.
Most people don't
know the Solomonic.
They followed them through.
They could have taken
that commercial airliner
out of the sky and
taken him with it.
But we are a country
that loves and respects
innocent human life.
But as soon as he
was on the tarmac
and we had a red dot on
them, satellite imaging,
we took the shot.
We took them out, we took
out Baghdadi and associates.
We took out the Al
Qaeda leader in Yemen.
So that's sort of the future,
but the beginning
of our relationship
started on disagreement
because he would get mad
at some of the things
I was saying on air
and we talk privately and
that's how our friendship began.
But I also began to notice--
And again, I was proud
of what I did with Obama.
I'm proud of seeing where this
was going with Donald Trump
cause I knew him and I
put everything on the line
because I was telling my
conservative friends he's well,
Hannity donated to Hillary.
Hannity, he said this
about this Democrat.
Legitimate arguments.
He said he was pro choice,
now he's saying he's pro life,
why do you believe him?
Because I knew it was true.
I knew it was real, I
knew it was sincere.
And the other thing
that I knew about him,
if he says something,
he means it
and he's going to
follow through on it.
He's one of these guys that
if you make a deal with them,
it is a deal.
You'll do his part
and he'll deliver
to the best of his ability.
And so listen, I had a lot of
conservatives furious with me
telling me he doesn't
mean it on judges.
He doesn't mean it on the wall.
He doesn't mean it on tax cuts.
He's not going to cut
out all the regulation.
He doesn't mean it on energy.
He doesn't mean
it on healthcare.
He meant all of it
and he did all of it
to the extent that he possibly
could and very successfully.
And that is not a story
that the mainstream media
will ever tell about the guy.
So I knew if I have
conservative credentials,
if I have them, whatever
people might say or not,
I put it on the line and I
told my conservative audience,
he will govern as
a conservative.
I've been proven right.
And, and you know, that's a hey,
I'm putting it all on the
line like I did with Obama.
- So for a guy that is
governing like a conservative,
that's pretty obvious
at this point.
One of the things that we've
talked about a couple of times
on your show is what's happening
in Portland, in Seattle,
in Chicago, in New York,
just the crazy situations
of violence and murder
and everything else because
of these progressive policies,
which by the way, years
ago, well before I knew you,
when I would flick on your show,
you were basically the only guy
that was talking about the
black on black crime in Chicago
and what would they do?
They would call you racist for
it for even bringing it up.
You'd say, well, 30 black
people died this weekend
and they would call
you the racist for it.
But are you concerned
at all that optics wise,
when Trump then sends
in the national guard
and we get federal
troops in these things
that this is playing
into the hand that,
oh, well you see, he's
the authoritarian.
He's the guy that
wanted to throw
all the federal troops
into the cities.
- Well, when Obama
said this week
that federal troops are
using tear gas and batons
on peaceful protesters,
that's not true.
And in spite of all
the video evidence
with Jerry Nadler
saying, this is a myth,
he actually said it,
or who would ever think
that a major party
presidential candidate
would say the words the police
are the enemy, like what?
And supporting
defunding the police.
I mean, Joe Biden has
yet to say a good thing
about the 99% of
police, men and women
that protect and
serve their cities.
All of them put their
lives on the line
for all of us every single day.
And so you ask a great question.
Donald Trump has not sent
in the national guard
unless they request it.
He's been begging New
York city and Chicago
and Portland and
Seattle, begging them,
let us help you
restore law and order
and safety and security.
You can't pursue
happiness, Dave Ruben,
without law and order
and a safe community.
If you're a one-year-old
shot in a park in New York,
dead in a stroller or an
eight year old little girl
killed in Atlanta because
her mom made a wrong turn
into the chop zone
near where the Wendy's,
that street had been taken
over, a new autonomous zone.
And that little girl in
the back of the car died
after getting shot in the
head or a seven year old
beautiful girl in Chicago died
on the 4th of July weekend
while at her grandmother's
house, you know,
playing on the 4th of July
or Horace Lorenzo Anderson Jr,
19 years old and his father,
that heart-wrenching
interview that I had with him.
It killed me, my
kids are 18 and 21.
Anyway, so the answer
is he's offering.
Now, that's separate and apart--
We're talking about
a hundred troops
that are being sent in to
protect federal property
and federal courthouses.
That's not only their
job, but their obligation
because they were trying
to burn them to the ground.
They're not there to restore
law and order to the cities
because the mayors
refuse to do it.
What do all of the cities
we're talking about,
New York, Chicago, Portland,
Seattle, Los Angeles,
the city of Atlanta, what
do they all have in common?
They've all been run by
liberal Democrats for decades.
Now, if you believe as I do,
and I get into a lot
of this in the book,
which is over your shoulder.
- Yeah, we're
going to get there.
We're going to get
there, I promise.
This does color a lot of
this stuff in the book.
- A lot of it, but
if you believe in our
founding document,
our founding document is
our declaration, right?
Some people think
it's the constitution.
No, the founding document.
What does it say?
I can remember it unlike,
you know, cookey Joe.
One of my favorite clippet,
"All these truths
to be self evident
that all men and women
are created" by the thing.
You know, the thing, the
thing, God, Joe, God,
the creator of everything.
All right, that scared me.
So, but if you believe in
that, what does that line mean?
Endowed by our creator means
that got rights for all of us
and I believe this with my
mind, my heart, my soul.
They come from God.
They don't come from man, they
don't come from government.
And that life, liberty,
pursuit of happiness,
how, Dave Reuben, you tell me,
how do you pursue happiness
if you're living in those
cities and you're not safe
in a park or your grandma's
backyard on the 4th of July,
or if your mom makes a
wrong turn on a city street,
or if your son is in
the summer of love zone
as mayor Durken said.
How do you pursue happiness
if you don't have basic law,
order, safety, security?
How do you pursue happiness
in all of these cities?
What is one other commonality?
They all have the worst
educational records
of most cities in the world.
We pay more per capita for
education than any other country
in the industrialized world.
These cities have this income.
We have failed our children.
If you look at a ladder, I
used to be a contractor, right?
You have the rungs
of the ladder, right?
Okay, you take
away that education
and I'll give you a little,
my background, I learned Latin,
I went to a seminary in high
school and the word education
from the Latin derivative
(speaks in foreign language)
to bring forth from within.
So if we believe that
God gives you rights,
if education is to bring forth
from what is already there
from God, talents he gave
you, well, you need safety,
security, you need education.
So okay, Joe Biden is
saying that the government
is going to take
care of everything
you ever want in your life.
He's going to take care
of a guaranteed job
at a guaranteed wage and K
through college education
and forgive student loans
and government
guaranteed vacations
guaranteed healthy food
and you're going
to have government
guaranteed healthcare,
and you're going to have a
government guaranteed retirement
and you don't have a
worry in the world.
I'll get to the
psychology of that.
Okay, what is the track
record in these liberal cities
that have been run by
liberals for decades,
which is what Joe Biden adopting
Bolshevik Bernie socialism
and AOC's new green deal.
And, bazo bozo as I
call him (talks quickly)
and bozos gun confiscation plan.
All right, so in these cities,
they don't give
security or safety.
In these cities, they
fail spectacularly
when it comes to education.
A specific example,
the city of Baltimore,
13 public high schools,
you want to venture a
guess what percentage
in the 13 schools, not 13
kids, 13 public high schools.
What percentage of
kids in those schools,
and you don't have to answer,
it's not a trick question.
- I'll ballpark it,
I'll try just to see.
- Do you believe are
proficient in math and reading?
Let's start with math.
- I'm going to guess, I'm going
to go obviously crazily low.
I'm going to get what, to
like 10%, something like that.
- Not one child in 13
public high schools,
Baltimore spends, they have
third highest per capita
per student spending
in the world.
Not one kid in 13 schools?
Okay, here's the ladder.
Why don't you just
take a sledgehammer,
rip out all the rungs and
beat out most sides of it
because you don't
have an education.
So they don't provide
security, safety, law, order,
they don't provide education.
All right, what else has
government done for us?
If we're going to
put all our hate,
if we're going to
believe Joe Biden
and Bernie socialist utopia
and AOC's new green deal.
Okay, and they're
going to take care
of every single need
we have in life.
Okay, how's social
security doing, Dave Ruben?
Because the last I
checked, you're screwed.
I'll probably get something
until they means test it
because it's headed
towards bankruptcy.
They'll raise the retirement age
to about 30 seconds before
you die you'll be eligible,
or they'll means test it and
you'll have paid in 50 years
and they'll rob you,
they'll legally rob you.
How's Medicare going?
That's headed for bankruptcy!
How did that Obamacare
promise thing work out?
Keep your doctor, keep
your plan and save money.
The average American will save
$2,500 per family per year.
Well, we now know what
Bidencare Obamacare did.
We had millions of Americans.
They lost their doctors,
millions lost their plans,
and we're all paying on
average about 200% more.
And it's even worse
because there's almost 40%
of the country that
only has one Biden,
Obamacare exchange opportunity.
There's only one choice.
In other words,
there's no choice,
because all of these
companies said, "We can't,
this doesn't work,
we can't do this."
So if you look at all of
the promises that government
had made up to this point,
and you look at the results,
they don't keep any promises.
You know, I have a chapter
in the book, socialism,
a history of failure.
Well, I did it purposely.
I did a chapter on what
makes America great.
Well, you know,
American exceptionalism.
It's Ben Franklin, a
republic if you can keep it.
Well, Reagan said freedom
is but one generation away
from extinction, right?
All our generations
have to fight for it.
You're in the much younger
generation, I was graduating.
You were born in 19 what?
- '76.
- Okay, I was graduating
grammar school in 1976
just to give you
some perspective.
And it was the
bicentennial at the time.
It was, and you
know, you look at--
I lost my train of thought here,
but I'm just looking
at all the things
that they're offering.
Oh, here it is.
I talk about America and what
made us great and successful,
that while we're not
a perfect nation,
we're the country that
abused power the least
as my friend, Barry Farber
said, after accumulating power.
I add to that, we have
taken all of the power
America's accumulated and
what do we do with it?
We beat back the forces
of fascism and Nazi-ism
ans communism and
Imperial Japan.
We protected freedom.
The history of
socialism is promises
just like the green new
deal, just like Obamacare,
just like, you know,
the educational system
and all the promises made
all these socialists utopias.
I don't care if it's
Mao and the revolution.
I don't care if it's the
Bolshevik revolution.
And I go through great
detail in each case.
I don't care if
it's East Germany,
what people, they
have a wall built
and the East Germans
want to get the hell out
and they're willing to get
shot or risk getting shot
trying to get over
to West Germany
where the life is much
better with freedom.
I don't care if it's
Cuba or Venezuela,
the promises are all there.
The reality, the truth of it is,
for every bit of security
you get promised,
you lose your freedom and they
never fulfill the promise.
You don't have to
have a Harvard degree
or be an MIT mathematician
or engineer to figure out,
Holy crap, this doesn't add
up, 94 trillion in 10 years.
And you're eliminating
oil, gas, and coal.
And at the same time,
we're offering everybody
everything for free
but we only take in four
and a half trillion a year.
We don't take in enough
money, simple math, 52,
what trillion in 10 years
for Medicare for all,
or Obamacare on steroids
as Joe is pushing.
- But Sean, as AOC said,
you don't have to do
what's factually correct,
you have to do
what's morally right.
And especially with
the way they do it.
- By her and the squad?
So these promises, you know,
this is the psychological
component I teased
a little bit ago and it's this.
Oh, everybody feels
stress in life.
My four grandparents
all came from Ireland.
I had my ancestry test, it
was a 100% British isle,
all Ireland, right?
And they said that's rare, I
was like really, and whatever.
All four of my grandparents came
from two counties in Ireland.
My mom and dad, we
grew up broke poor.
My dad, you mentioned Brooklyn.
I'm interested where,
because my dad grew up
in Bed-Stuy in
Brooklyn, really poor.
- Flatbush, Flatbush.
- Flatbush, okay,
I know a lot of--
I had a few friends in Flatbush,
but a little before your time.
I was incorrigible,
they were incorrigible.
That's why you're incorrigible.
- That's old school Brooklyn.
- Old school Brooklyn, big time.
But my dad grew up poor,
lost his mom complications
from his childbirth
just a few weeks
after he was born.
You know, shuffled
around a family member
after family member
cause his dad was working
just to survive.
And my mom grew up
in the South Bronx.
She became a prison guard.
He became a family
court probation guy
and a waiter on the weekends.
And it was a big deal
to get out of Bed-Stuy
in the South Bronx and
got a 50 by a hundred lot
where I grew up in Franklin
square, long Island.
And and with three older
sisters and one bathroom
that's called hell on earth
for me, it traumatized me.
I had to run out
to the bushes a lot
cause they were often in
there for hours on end
with the makeup or whatever.
But I know that I stand
on their shoulders.
They had no guarantees,
but the idea of freedom
to them was that
they will build a better
life for their children
and their grandchildren.
I literally know I stand on
the shoulders of my parents
who stand on the shoulders
of my grandparents
and those that came before them.
I never thought when I got
behind a radio microphone
in 1987 or eight, I
forget the exact year,
that I would ever
have any success.
I've always felt
that my radio career
is going to end any day.
My TV career, I'm
doing my last show.
This is probably
my last podcast,
you're about to kill my groove.
- Is it Hannity, you're done.
- And I never, you know, when
I worked for free in radio
I never thought I'd
get anywhere with it,
I just knew I loved it.
The light went on
and whatever this is
that you see started
flying out of me.
And I had to, you know,
eventually you always
find your own voice
in radio and TV, your
own individuality,
you usually start out like stern
and what I described earlier
as all right, "Hello,
today's weather,
hazy, hot, humid.
And you know, chances of
afternoon thunderstorms.
We all do that
stupid radio thing.
But anyway, but then I just
pursued it cause I loved it.
Not expecting any success.
My first paid job
was 19 grand a year
in Huntsville, Alabama.
I went to, you know,
Atlanta after that,
then I started doing,
believe it or not,
I was on fake news
CNN all the time
because they needed
somebody who would kind of
drop a little controversy
into their shows
and I used to go down there.
They would call me, "All right,
cam you come to the
12 o'clock show?
Can you do the
one o'clock show?"
And I went there a lot and
that led to opportunities
in New York, which you know,
I got very blessed
and very fortunate.
And when I started at Fox, I
remember saying to my friend,
"Do you think we'll
last three years,
we'll get three
years out of this?"
No, it's now you're at 25.
- They did all right.
- I thank those, my
parents and grandparents,
they made it possible,
they took the risk.
They lived the hard life.
Mine's hard too,
I'm not gonna lie.
This is not, you know,
I'm grinding 24/7.
- Yeah, the stakes are
probably a little fancier,
but you know, it's pretty good.
- Want to know the truth?
I was happy going
to Tad's steakhouse
when I first moved to New
York, it's like eight bucks.
You get a T-bone steak,
potato and a vegetable.
I was like, this is heaven.
(talk over each other)
- Does that place still exist?
I remember the one in Times
Square, I used to have--
- No, it just went away.
The last one went
down, how long ago?
About a year ago.
It was like two years
ago I sent my assistant,
go get me a Tad steak just
cause I liked it, that was it.
- It's a greasy
Times Square steak.
So, I love that you just
told the story of your family
because you know, I go into
that in my book as well
that we are, we
all are, you know,
my great grandparents
fled Europe.
And then my grandfather grew
up one bedroom, six kids.
His father died when he was
two, he was lower middle class.
My parents were middle
class, I'm doing all right.
I mean, it's the
beautiful thing,
but let's link all
of this to your book
because what we've been
talking about here,
it sort of all is
bouncing around the book.
But you and I share one
special thing in common,
beyond the New York thing,
which is that we do see
the progressive movement
as the greatest threat
to liberty and freedom
and everything else
we've spoke about here.
For some of my pure
YouTube people,
they probably don't know
you used to host a show
with Alan Combs,
who was a liberal.
He was a liberal,
he's passed on since,
but you were the conservative,
he was the liberal.
And I would say he was more
of an old school liberal.
He wasn't a sorta
crazy bananas lefty.
- No, let me fix that.
He was crazy left,
he drove me crazy.
Listen, the nicest man in
the world, heart of gold,
but he actually believed that
crap and it drove me crazy,
but we ended up getting along.
- Was he really--
See, maybe that is a little
bit of just my memory as a kid,
but I re--
- He was pretty hardcore.
We used to try and reign
them in a little bit.
- Sorry, so whether he was
crazy lefty or whatever,
I assume you recognize
that there once were
sort of sane liberals.
You just kind of disagreed
with them, is that fair to say?
- Yeah, I was telling
Joel Pollak this,
I liked from Breitbart in
an interview I did with him.
I knew that it used
to be we called them
scoop Jackson Democrats, right?
Or more modern times,
but nobody knows what
I'm talking about,
or Joe Lieberman.
When Joe Lieberman, who I
happened to be friends with,
love the guy, nice human,
wonderful human being,
wonderful family.
And he and I share a passion,
you know, for Israel,
you know, our closest
ally in the middle East,
the only democracy
in the region.
And he also stood strong against
radical Islamic terrorism,
which it is a real
threat to the world.
The reason the Iranians now,
or you have this new Alliance
that might have been
unimaginable five years ago
between the US, Israel, the
Saudis, Jordan, the Egyptians,
the Emirates is because
they understand, you know,
the threat of a raiding hegemony
and their pursuit
of nuclear weapons.
That is a clear and present
danger for the world.
So something that maybe was
unheard of even five years ago,
you know, this is
a real Alliance,
a real threat that Iran poses;
I've known Bibi Netanyahu, man,
that goes back 30
years, 25 years,
like with president Trump.
And I've been to Israel a
number of times, and you know,
I've learned so much
history being there,
but there's been no
president, by the way,
that's done more for Israel,
that's done more for
religious freedom,
that's done more for any
of these pivotal issues
than Donald J. Trump.
The best friend Israel ever
had has been Donald Trump.
The best friends Christians
in America has ever had
has been Donald Trump.
The best friend of religious
freedom has been Donald Trump
as evidenced by his action.
- You're telling me
Trump's not an anti-Semite,
he's not a racist,
he's not a homophobe?
I can't believe it's Sean,
that's what they tell me.
- Well, I read the
same stuff you do.
That's what they say about
us too, they attack us all.
Here's the thing, but that
party is so extreme now,
that old democratic
party is gone.
When they went against Joe,
I'm like, wow, a nice guy.
He has a different
view on foreign policy
and they defeated
him in the primary.
He ran as an
independent and he won.
And you know, I think
it speaks volumes,
there are no moderates I argue
in the democratic party
today, they don't exist.
Not with this bunch that we
now have and that's the danger.
If you want to go bring
this full circle here.
That is now the danger
of if Biden wins,
here's what we get.
His stated policy, he's
chosen his economic czar,
actually plagiarize it,
which he has a long
history of plagiarism.
Bernie Sanders, radical
socialism for the economy.
He's adopted and pledged
trillions of dollars
to AOC's green new deal.
He's bozo as I said
earlier, he's the gunzar,
then you add Pelosi,
Schumer and Biden
you've got 125 years of failure.
I have a question for everyone
that watches your podcast.
Can you tell me one
thing Joe Biden has done
for 47 years in the swamp?
One thing, one accomplishment
you can point to
that you could say, "Joe
Biden made that happen
and we're better
off because of it."
Cause I can give
you a, you know,
chapter and verse and a
list as long as you want
about what Donald
Trump accomplished
in less than four years.
- He got his son
a pretty good gig
at a gas company in Ukraine,
that counts as something, right?
- Zero experience Hunter,
quid pro quo, Joe.
Yes, you watched the show.
- Do you think Biden is
going to be the nominee?
I've been saying it for months.
Like they could just take
him out at any moment
or he'll announce
that he can't do it
or they'll say it's
a medical thing,
or do you think they're really
just trying to smuggle him in
so that the VP can be in charge
with the party apparatus
or whatever else?
- When have we ever
watched a candidate
that gets the party nomination
usually, historically,
and Donald Trump
is the exception.
He campaigned for
the primary one way.
He stayed campaigning the
same way in the general.
He won and then he
fulfilled his promises.
Historically it's been,
you go right, you go left.
And then when the
general election comes
after you get the nomination
you'll move to the center.
He's so weak, this is a
sign of real weakness.
Well, the Bernie people are
still not supporting him,
even though he actually
plagiarized their
economic agenda.
You know, there are still
members of the squad
that are not
supporting Joe Biden.
Are the Democrats
capable of anything?
Well, they dragged the
country down the sewer
with three years of a total
setup, abuse of power,
conspiracy theories and a hoax
when we now know they
knew from day one,
there was never, ever,
ever any Russia collusion.
The only collusion
was Hillary Clinton's
30 Russian
misinformation dossier.
That was then used to
these FISA applications,
premeditated fraud on a court
for the purpose of
taking away Carter Page's
civil liberties,
constitutional rights
and spying on Trump's campaign,
his transition team and
deep into his presidency.
And I hope we're
going to get justice
because we need justice
before the 2020 election
and need to know exactly
what went on in 2016.
- Do you think they're going
to keep pushing on that?
Because it almost seems--
I've interviewed Rick
Grenell a couple of times
and we've talked about this
and he firmly believes
everything that
you just said there
and he was the acting
intelligence secretary.
- He did an amazing job.
(talk over each other)
- Right, but part of
me sort of feels like
they're going to let
it go no matter what
because there's so much crap
flying around the country.
I mean, we've just done an hour.
We didn't even talk about
coronavirus for a second,
which by the way, people
will say to me, Ruben,
you're going on Hannity's show.
He's such an
extremist and Corona
and every time I'm
on there with you,
you're screaming about
everyone putting on a mask
at a supermarket and you know,
I'm here and I'm like, eh,
with the masks or whatever.
- Well, I say that
for a reason though.
I mean, if you're interested,
we can go into that in a minute.
You want to finish
your other thought?
- Yeah, well why don't
we finish up with that.
But the point being that
I sense they're going to
sort of let the stuff that
Obama's administration did go
because there's just so
much other stuff right now
and we can only as a nation,
we can kind of only deal with
so many problems at once.
That may not be right or just,
but it just strikes me
as sort of how it is.
- I think it's
downright dangerous.
Look, because what
you're then saying is
is that we have a
dual justice system.
What you're saying is we
don't have equal justice
under the law,
what you're saying,
we would be accepting,
is we don't have equal
application of our laws
because based on
what we know now
is they knew Hillary
violated the Espionage Act.
This is the great
hypocrisy of Democrats.
It blows my mind,
to be a Democrat
or to be part of the
mob in the media.
Oh, you take a sip, I've
been taking sips all night.
- Go crazy over there.
Except this is vodka man.
- Yeah okay, well you
could have told me,
I would have had a drink
with you cause I love--
I like Tito's, that's
my favorite vodka.
So what do you have to
be to be a Democrat?
You have to ignore
Hillary Clinton's
violation of the
Espionage Act, 18 USC 793.
It's insane that I have
that tattooed in my brain.
You have to forget
that subpoenaed emails
were deleted and then (talks
quickly) and then the hammers,
but you'll accuse Trump.
You'll be all out feigning
all the outrage over Trump
and the Mueller report not
giving a final conclusion
on obstruction, which
the attorney general
and Rod Rosenstein did,
which is there is none.
They're all concerned about
Russia, Russia, Russia,
Russia, Russia, but they didn't
give a rip about the dirty.
Even the "New York Times"
has finally called it
likely Russian
disinformation dossier
that she paid for
with funnel money
through a law firm to Fusion
GPS, hiring Christopher Steele.
Now we know that they were
setting Trump up for this
in August of 2016.
Now we know before the
first FISA application
that they were warned
that it's not verified.
It says at the top of a
FISA warrant verified,
it was unverifiable,
now it's been debunked.
Now we know that they were told
don't trust Christopher Steele,
he's got a political agenda.
Hillary paid for
it, it's unverified,
but they used it anyway.
And they did it despite
a presidential candidate
then transition then
team then presidency.
If we allow that
breathtaking hypocrisy to go,
because look what
they did to Manafort.
Pre-dawn raid, guns in
the face of his wife
or Roger Stone, pre-dawn raid,
29 guys in tactical gear,
frogman and CNN
camera's tipped off.
And I'm like, okay,
Jim Colby was,
there was a referral for
him for lying to Congress,
where's his pre-dawn raid?
Where's McCabe's predawn raid?
Where's the pre-dawn raid
on a lot of these people
that I've talked so much about?
And in every single case, if
we don't have justice here,
if they get away
with it, number one,
we're going to have
a lot more of it.
Number two, as a country,
you might as well
take your constitution
and take it to your shredder
and just shred it or burn it
because it's meaningless
because that is what
the rule of law is
supposed to be about.
I am confident, I do believe
late August, early September,
there's going to be
major developments
because it's all out
there in the open.
What we now have available
in the public domain,
and I spent over three
years on the show,
almost three and a half years
really working hard with
a small ensemble cast
exposing a lot of this,
is enough that could lead
to convening a grand jury,
indictments and
convictions in my view,
and in the view of
everybody that I know
that knows everything, so we
better get to the bottom of it.
- And just to be clear,
I wasn't saying we
should let it go.
I was just saying that
that it sometimes seems
that the news cycle
or the national cycle,
it's like we deal with so
many things at one time.
All right, so let's finish up
with some coronavirus stuff,
because that is one of the
things as I've in the last year,
as I've done Fox
more and especially
in the last couple of weeks.
- You hate that I
talk about masks?
- Yeah, well people will
say, oh, you're on Fox,
but they were misleading
everyone about coronavirus
and blah, blah, blah.
Meanwhile, there's
video of Gutfeld.
I think it's the earliest
that I've seen it on cable,
I think it's January 28th,
Gutfeld talking
about coronavirus.
There were many democratic
debates after that
where nobody---
- I might have him beat,
January 27th I had Fauci on.
- I mean, that's incredible.
All right, so then there you go.
We're gonna check that
cause we like to fact check.
- You can check it, and I add
them on February 10th again.
- But there you go.
I mean, the fact that every
time when I've been on your show
to talk about lockdowns
or whatever it may be,
you make a point of saying
that when you're in the stores,
you're wearing a mask and
that you want the people
to be wearing a
mask and all that.
What do you make of just
the general misinformation
and the conflicting information
and Fauci says this one day,
the CDC the next day with this
and now Twitter--
- This week he just added
goggles, that was new.
Now we might need goggles.
- The face shield
and the goggles.
- Look, all I can tell
you is my own experience
and it's anecdotal but
to me it speaks volumes.
Is I remember a Saturday,
it was one Saturday
and within a period
of like 36 hours,
there were around, I
was getting reports,
18,000 new cases of Corona
just in long Island.
And I'm like, I mean, I
remember being on the phone
and I'm out there like
this I'm like, oh my God.
I mean, I felt the weight
of the world that moment
in my mind, in my heart.
And I'm like, this is bad.
And then I'm talking
to friends of mine
that work in hospitals.
We're now at capacity
and now we're in trouble.
And I remember calling a
lot of people about that
at the time and I
was very concerned,
but all throughout the middle
of the epicenter of this,
New York lost 36,000 people,
we now know why because
of the dopey governor
and the dopey mayor,
just like the dopey
governor of New Jersey
and the dopey governor
of Pennsylvania
and the same in Michigan.
But when I would go
to my grocery store,
my drug store locally, which
I'd go every single week.
And every time I went there,
I saw the same cashiers.
I saw the same guy stocking
the shelves every single time.
Remember, if the
Packers stopped packing
and the farmers stopped farming
and the truckers
stopped trucking,
New York would have
starved to death
and we wouldn't have had any PPP
and 10s of thousands more
at least would have died,
but they worked, we didn't
shut down everything.
But I would see, I actually
interviewed this kid.
He's 19 years old,
he's named Robert,
every week I go to the
store once or twice
and every time he was there
he was stocking the shelves.
You know, once or twice
the no toilet paper.
I don't know why there's
always a run on toilet paper
and paper towels, but
I'm like, whatever.
But I see this kid every week.
He had his mask on,
he had his gloves on ,
everybody in the store had it,
not a single person, not
one ever contracted Corona.
Now in the middle of
the biggest shit show
at the height, the epicenter,
I'm using an
anecdotally, it works.
Now, why would I wear a mask?
Cause what, the government's
going to tell me
to wear a mask?
I'm not saying anybody
mandate anything.
I'm saying I choose to
because of what I learned
being in the middle
of it at the time.
I do it for selfish reasons
and I do it for this reason.
One reason is we know one
thing that remained the same
and the models were wrong
and the doctors were wrong
and the experts were wrong
and the governors were wrong
and TV pundits were wrong
and everybody was wrong.
And China lied to the world,
people forget that part of it.
But the one thing that
remained steady and consistent
that older with
underlying conditions
and compromised immune systems,
they were the most vulnerable.
So that never changed
all throughout this.
That's why, even though
you have, you know,
the second wave that
hit Florida and Texas,
you don't have anywhere
near the death rate.
It's like this, you know.
Actually, I think
Texas and Florida,
what did I read this week?
That combined, their
deaths, you know,
for the whole time didn't
even match separately
each state just one
day in New York.
The difference is that stark
because Ron DeSantis
and governor Abbott,
they protected the elderly
population of their States.
So I say it that,
okay, I want to protect
grandma, grandpa, mom and dad
and my parents and
grandparents are long gone,
but I don't want to
infect anybody else's
grandparents or parents.
And I also selfishly,
if it means I can go to a
baseball game or football game
but I have to wear a mask
and have my temperature taken
as I walk in, I'm
willing to do that
because I want
like back to normal
and I think we can do
it and do it safely.
But the other thing is, it's
going to be very short term
because we're getting
closer and closer.
Therapeutics have improved.
Two studies now came out.
The one study that said
hydroxychloroquine is awful,
they had to retract that study!
The two studies that came
out at the Ford center.
There's a system in New
York, a hospital system,
Dr. Oz talked about a lot.
They suggest the opposite,
taken early with zinc
and azithromycin,
it dramatically saved lives
and had an impact taken early.
The president this week talking
about convalescent plasma,
asking people with antibodies,
donate your plasma,
donate your blood.
I think those are for people
that are a little bit sicker,
which would help save
again more lives.
We never broke down
the sequence of a virus
as fast as we did here,
which is six weeks.
It used to take six years.
We could actually be in a
situation where we're now
in the final phase trials,
Maderna, AstraZeneca, Pfizer,
where we're we could have
within nine months a vaccine
and this is the worst
pandemic since 1918.
Now add to that, what
did president Trump do?
Okay, nobody was
prepared for anything,
but the president mobilized
and the president got
all the ventilators.
We never ran out of
ventilators, all the masks,
all the gloves, all the
PPE and built hospitals.
Then he manned the hospitals,
provided all the PPE
for the hospitals.
Then converted hospitals like
the Javits center, 3000 beds.
They only used a
1000 or the Comfort
or the Mercy out west
and converted it to
COVID capability.
And those idiot governors
in New York, New Jersey,
Pennsylvania, and
Michigan, you know,
they're sending people with
COVID into nursing homes
and that's where thousands
and thousands and thousands
of innocent people were infected
that we could have saved.
Just total incompetence.
Donald Trump will never
get credit for two things.
The fastest and the biggest
and largest medical mobilization
in the history of mankind
and he got it done.
It wasn't easy, got it done.
And also operation warp speed,
getting us to therapeutics.
And now we're on the verge
I believe of that vaccine.
And the next thing
he did is something
that nobody ever
gives him credit for.
The first identified case of
Corona in the United States
was January 21st this year.
The travel ban was put
into effect 10 days later,
the one that Biden called
historical xenophobia
and fear-mongering.
The Democrats were
busy impeaching Donald
Trump at the time
when he put the
travel ban in effect,
then subsequent travel bands
and the first quarantine
in effect in over 50 years.
It is incalculable how many
10s of thousands of Americans
likely would have
contracted and died
had he not acted that early.
It would have been
exponentially worse.
Biden, Schumer, Peloski,
they were just out there
impeaching Donald Trump.
So I give him very high marks.
I think it's unfair the
way he's been treated.
Did we do everything perfectly?
No, we didn't, nobody knew.
You know, I like Fauci.
I think Fauci has dedicated
his entire life to medicine
and saving lives,
his heart is sincere.
He got it wrong, not
a criticism, China
lied to the world.
The models, you know,
first models were saying
two and a half million
dead Americans.
Then it was 60,000 and
then it was 80,000.
Now it's 150,000 deaths
that we know so far.
We have gotten better
at the hotspots.
We've gotten better
at therapeutics.
We're on the verge I
believe of a vaccine.
Masks for me were anecdotal.
I'm not forcing
you to wear a mask.
If you don't want to wear a
mask, I don't give a fine rip.
Don't wear a mask, but
you're not going to
get into a baseball
game or football game.
- Listen, I wear it where
you have to wear it.
But if I'm walking my dog and
I'm not near anybody else,
I'm not wearing a mask,
but I totally get you.
- And I don't like
government mandating it.
You know what, I don't.
Now, if stores want to
have rules and regulations
say if you don't have a mass
we're not going to let you in,
I think they have the
right to say that.
- [Dave] Yeah I agree.
- And if stadiums want to
say if you don't wear a mask,
we can't let you in.
If you have a high temperature,
It's temporary.
I'd even tell older people
until we really got this thing
fully under control, and I
think we're that close now,
just for a short period of time,
the CDC in the last two
weeks actually put out
that if everybody
would volunteer
and agree to wear masks
for four to eight weeks,
it's over, we'll wipe it
out, no more hotspots.
The president has been pushing
it and social distancing
and all the things we
talk about all the time.
But the therapeutics,
it's going to be medical.
It's going to be
freedom and liberty,
which is at risk in what, 90
whatever days is in play here.
So am I talking too much?
I feel like I've just--
- No, listen man, you
brought it around,
you brought it around.
Everything that we
talked about here,
even though we didn't dive
into the book tremendously,
everything we talked about here
is exactly what
the book is about
because you're trying to
show people that freedom
is on the precipice of
going the wrong way.
That's what the book is about.
And you know, you said
a lot of nice things
about me at the beginning.
So let me just say
this, that we have not,
we have never met in person.
Until the 10 seconds we
talked before we started this,
we've never even spoke
off camera before,
but you've become a great
ally and friend of mine
and you helped me
out with the book
by putting me on all the time,
and I hope I've added a
little something to your show
and we're going to link
to your book down below.
So I thank you, Sean.
- You've become part
of our ensemble cast,
you're a part of our team
now, and you earned it.
I remember the first
time you were on.
I wrote my producer
while you were on,
by the way, little secret,
I can text and do shows at warp
speed while I'm on the air.
Even reading.
- I'm not at that level yet.
- You will be, it's called
HD, what do you call it?
ADHD on steroids, there
you go, I got it right.
But thank you for being such
a good friend of our program.
You give me a lot of
time here, thank you.
This book is about if we lose
this election, in my view,
their stated agenda will destroy
the greatest wealth producing
system ever designed by man
that has advanced
the human condition
more than all other societies
ever combined before.
That's what's at stake.
And if you're going to
vote for the president,
I hope you vote down ticket,
"Live Free or Die" is
about really simple.
Their policies of false promises
will destroy the greatest
country God gave man.
I don't want that to
happen with all my heart.
- The book is
"Live Free or Die."
The link is right
down below and Sean,
when you leave New
York and I leave LA,
I guess we're going
to meet in Montana
and the Tito's is on me.
- Okay bring a lot, cause
I can drink more than you.
This is really been
Tito's the whole time.
I just haven't slurred
like Joe Biden yet.
Hey, listen, honestly,
thanks so much.
- You are an Irishman, I get it.
- Thanks so much for having me.
Thanks for being a gracious
host and a gracious guest
on our show and your book's
been phenomenal and did so well.
You should be very proud
and I'm very honored
to have been on with
with you, thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out the full
episode playlist.
They're both right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.